olá pessoal estamos da noite ó tu que
com a tua amiga leitora gosto de tudo
isso nós vamos buscar o caso agora nós
não inventamos a afinar conhecimento
jogo do calor tudo é um jogo que não
jogo muito mexe eu acho que vou jogar já
de si com um caminho diferente portanto
espero que seja difícil sair toda
escuridão o flash é fácil não conseguem
ver o pessoal do preço das trevas não
sei se fico louco ou sul no sul da
estréia eu já escolhi lisboa e vai dar
dinheiro que lá do [ __ ] mas denunciou
o caso e mora longe pra [ __ ] caso
mora lá numa casa no meio desculpas e
afirmou que todo o volume de casas e
moram há um dos cabos pastor ainda temos
nos falta de dez minutos e eu não tô
acostumado muito fazer volta espero que
vocês gostem pessoal eu continuar com o
caso e depois voltar a comprar fazer com
esse dinheiro faz muita gente
eu sou a mãe do bruno e outro no pé
nós choramos muito e cheguei para josé
mota não só é de que já no evento de
carros do japão kazuo renda e aproximou
a história
ae
do lixo
pinta porta fechada a nada
em troca
mas eu não dei uma entrevista pra ir
deitar e da rocha que foram 15
fica por conta do chá danada
vamos perder ficará o colo mesmo menina
tudo para não fazer feio tudo bem a
gente saiba que vemos o meu cachorro
também são bernardo que faz se com isso
ea marinha vai aumentar para tatu da
mata